la parole à monsieur philippe paul pour
le groupe ump
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse également à monsieur guillaume
garot est relative à la situation
l'industrie agroalimentaire dans le
finistère monsieur le ministre depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant l'industrie
agroalimentaire du finistère traverse
une crise brutale d'une ampleur sans
précédent
en février dernier l'abattoir gad à
lampaul-guimiliau était placée en
redressement judiciaire
à ce jour aucun repreneur ne s'est
manifesté aucun faisant peser une menace
de fermeture du site en août prochain et
la disparition de près de 850 emplois
début juin la société marinard ouest
kristen spécialisée dans la
transformation de saumon annonçait la
fermeture l'an prochain de ses sites de
poullaouen dans le finistère et de
châteaugiron en ille-et-vilaine soit la
suppression de plus de 400 postes au
total en l'espace de quelques semaines
ce sont plus de 1000 emplois qui sont
remis en cause sur le finistère plus de
1000 emplois c'est une véritable
tragédie pour les familles pour
l'activité des communes concernées et je
pourrais également évoqué le groupe doux
toujours en redressement judiciaire qui
depuis un an a perdu près de 1000
emplois lui aussi monsieur le ministre
vous connaissez bien l'agriculture et
l'agroalimentaire bretonne et
finistérienne vous connaissez leur poids
dans l'économie régionale elles en sont
les moteurs élus salariés acteurs
économiques locaux ont clairement
exprimé leur détermination et leur
volonté de se battre est de rechercher
des solutions pour sauver ces différents
outils de production et de
transformation
pour ne reprendre que l'exemple de
l'abattoir gad n'est-il pas
incompréhensible et paradoxale
d'envisager la fermeture d'un outil
performant implanté dans un des bassins
de production porcine les plus
concentrées et les plus dynamiques
d'europe qui de plus réuni tous les
agréments nécessaires à l'export
n'est-il pas incompréhensible et
paradoxale d'envisager la fermeture d'un
outil qui permet de produire et de
transformante et transformé par don au
plus près d'une zone de production et de
garantir ainsi une traçabilité parfaite
devons-nous nous résoudre à voir des
dizaines de milliers de porcs produits
en bretagne être abattue en allemagne
phénomène qui touche bien d'autres
régions françaises d'ailleurs monsieur
le ministre quand on est vous faire pour
éviter que l'agroalimentaire bretonne et
finistérienne ne continue à sombrer
quelles initiatives fortes le
gouvernement entente il prendre pour
accompagner ces territoires inquiet et à
juste titre pour leur avenir je vous
remercie merci monsieur guillaume garot
ministre chargé de la grande isle en
terre
monsieur le sénateur paul vous l'avez
vous l'avez rappelé certains pans de
l'industrie agréé l agroalimentaire
traverse aujourd'hui une crise très
lourde et la bretagne en particulier
finistère n'est pas épargné vous avez
évoqué la situation de plusieurs sites
gad doux marine harvest et je vais vous
le dire pour chacun de ces sites nous
sommes au combat nous sommes au combat
pour trouver des solutions et pour
préserver un maximum d'emplois nous
avons rencontré les salariés de gamme
nous avons rencontré les salariés de
doux et nous rencontrerons dans les
prochains jours en lien avec stéphane le
foll et avec michel sapin les salariés
de marine harvest mais sans attendre
nous avons pris dès le mois d'avril je
dis bien dès le mois d'avril avec
stéphane le foll des orientations fortes
à la fois pour répondre à l'urgence et
pour tracer de vraies perspectives
d'avenir et nous avons bâti en
particulier avec les professionnels un
plan pour relancer l'élevage pour
relancer la filière porcine et la
filière volaille en faisant de la
performance écologique un levier un vrai
levier de la performance économique nous
sommes engagés nous nous sommes engagés
à assouplir les démarches
administratives pour les installations
classées en particulier hier hier nous
avons signé avec tous les acteurs de la
filière alimentaire un contrat le
contrat de la filière alimentaire et ce
contrat pourra devra être mis en oeuvre
très vite pour la bretagne afin de
stimuler l'emploi et de moderniser
l'ensemble de nos secteurs enfin vous le
savez nous avons travaillé avec tous les
élus avec tous les élus bretons sur
l'actualité et l'avenir de notre filière
agroalimentaire nous avons organisé
plusieurs temps de travail pour
mobiliser tous les acteurs concernés et
vous y avez d'ailleurs participé alors
monsieur le sénateur
j'entends bien aujourd'hui votre
question nous sommes pleinement
conscients de la situation tout à fait
spécifique de la bretagne sachez que
nous travaillons d'arrache-pied pour
consolider et même pour développer le
potentiel agro alimentaire de la
bretagne parce que la filière
alimentaire doit rester une force pour
toute la région bretagne